Speaker 1: I want to start today with sort
of two economic stories that are kind of coming
together as one one, I find more interesting,
one I find less interesting.
The first piece is this issue of inflation
and inflation fears, and we again have data
which will look at that.
Prices went up again in the month of September.
The second part of this, I really am kind
of struggling to take it totally seriously,
although there is there is an interesting
piece to it, which is fears of toy shortages
for the Christmas season.
Now, the reason I have trouble sort of taking
it totally seriously is given everything that's
going on, everything we've had going on with
the pandemic, all sorts of different calamities
and crises and different things.
If there's not every toy available at Christmas.
It doesn't strike me as the absolute worst
thing in the world.
But it's it's interesting insofar as it relates
to the continued supply shortages for a number
of different reasons that we've been seeing.
So let's start with the inflation piece.
Reuters reporting U.S. consumer prices increased
solidly in September, poised to rise further
in the months ahead amid a surge in the costs
of energy products, which would cast doubt
on the Federal Reserve's view that high inflation
is transitory.
This has been the debate is this are we seeing
sort of some catch up inflation relative to
the declines due to the 2020 pandemic due
to the pandemic in 2020, the pandemic still
going on, but the effects of the pandemic
in 2020?
Or are we seeing the start of some real inflation?
The consumer price index rose 0.4 percent
last month after climbing 0.3 percent in August,
the Labor Department said Wednesday.
In the 12 months through September, the CPI
increased 5.4 percent after advancing five
point three percent year on year in August.
Excluding the volatile food and energy components,
the CPI climbed 0.2 percent after edging up
0.1 percent.
So what if you don't include food and energy?
The increase has been very modest.
However, food and energy are significant expenses
for many households, particularly, you know,
one of the things about food and energy.
And this we've talked about this before, but
I think it bears repeating there is a sort
of regressive aspect to food and energy spending.
And what I mean by that is if you're really,
really rich.
You're not necessarily going to be driving
that much more.
You might have a car that's less energy efficient
or one that's more energy efficient.
OK, if you're doing private jet travel, then
yes, if you're very rich, you actually are
going to spend a lot more on fuel.
But in terms of like driving a car or heating
your home.
Yes, if you have a significantly bigger home,
you'll pay a lot more to heat it.
But relative to your income relative to your
net worth, it's not going to be that much
more so in that sense.
Energy cost increases, fuel and home heating,
electricity for cooling as well.
They hit the poor more than they do the rich.
Similarly, with food.
OK, if you're wealthy, you might buy everything
organic at the most expensive grocery store.
But just because you make 50 times more than
someone else, you're not likely to spend 50
times more on food.
So this idea of if we exclude these two categories
energy and food, the increase isn't that much.
Well, those are categories that disproportionately
affect the middle class, lower middle class
and the poor.
Oil prices jumped Monday to the highest level
in years.
Expensive energy products would add to accelerating
wage growth in exerting upward pressure on
inflation.
The government reported last week that average
hourly earnings increased by the most in seven
months on a year on year basis because of
worker shortages.
With the number of people voluntarily quitting
jobs at a record high in August, at least
ten point four million unfilled positions,
wage inflation is set to rise further.
So this is one piece of the story.
The other piece, which again, I'm sort of
like, OK, I mean, I get it, but it's also.
It is what it is, toymakers warn delays in
stocking retail shelves could create a four
month holiday hangover.
Power outages in China, a resin shortage and
high labor costs have also strained the supply
of goods and increased prices.
The blockage of the Suez Canal in March is
part of the bottleneck.
Some questions about shares, which we don't
care that much about, but there may be delays
in getting people toys, so what?
What's the big picture here?
We may be heading towards real inflation,
meaning not just rebound relative as an artifact
relative to the pandemic.
We said this six months ago.
We need to continue watching it now.
There's another piece that's important to
understand which is is inflation good or bad?
This is sort of like a fundamental question
if you accept and many of us don't.
But if you if I if we accept traditional economic
thinking based on, at least for now, indefinite
growth, you want a little bit of inflation.
Why some people think, no, you don't want
prices going up, you want prices going down.
That's good for people.
It's good for consumers or prices.
Stay the same people buy stuff because you
expect that prices will be a little bit higher
in the future.
Maybe not consciously.
But let me put it a different way.
If you're looking for a car, if you're looking
for a home, if you're looking for toys, if
you expect prices to go down, that would discourage
you from buying right now because if you wait,
you can pay less.
If everybody did that because they expected
prices to be lower in the future.
Nobody would buy stuff and this would actually
create create a deflationary spiral, which
could depress wages.
It can put small businesses out of business,
et cetera.
If you have tons of inflation, people just
can't afford stuff.
Wages don't keep up.
People can't afford stuff.
So this is where the mentality of you want
a little bit of inflation.
That's where wage growth comes from.
To the extent that we have wage growth, that's
where business profit comes from, etc.
So when we talk about inflation, it's important
to understand that traditional economics doesn't
say any inflation is bad.
In fact, we have a sort of global economy
and status quo based on a little bit of inflation.
You expect things to be a little more expensive
in the future.
So you're going to go out and buy them today.
And this creates revenues for businesses with
which they pay employees, the money with which
those employees go and buy things and sort
of keep this train going now if you don't
believe in unlimited growth.
Then at some point, the paradigm has to shift.
But in terms of the immediate impact, we are
seeing sectors experience inflation that disproportionately
affect the middle class, lower middle class
and the poor, and we'll just have to continue
tracking those data.